(laughs)
(upbeat music)
My name is Yoya Takahashi.
I'm owner Hamasaku Restaurant.
And being making sushi for 20 years.
So, today
I gotta introduce this,
making sushi candy, okay?
For me, it's gonna be
easy, this is 100 percent,
I can make, for sure, so, let's start.
(speaks in foreign language)
See what's going on,
I'm gonna open box.
I'm kinda exciting. (laughs)
Here you go, I don't know what's exactly.
I gotta figure it out late, open up.
(salsa music)
Okay, kind of something weird.
See what ingredients they have.
Eggs, this is ikura, salmon roe.
Oh, this is tuna, this is most
famous, soy sauce right here.
This is my
rice, sounds
good, another ikura here.
I think this is seaweed,
anyway, first things.
I think I need to put on the
water, they have lines inside.
Number one.
(laughs)
Open rice candy powder,
is candy powder open?
Throw in the whole things. (laughs)
And then mix it like
sushi rice with vinegar.
Here you go, it smells like sweet candy.
It's kind of funny, see
that, look like rice, no?
Just keep going, looking nice, huh?
Number two is gonna be tuna,
again, just keep going.
Oops, I threw in too much, open up.
(laughs) Is that funny?
Yes, it is, I'm so sorry
about that, so sorry.
I have to be serious, yes.
Sushi chef be always strong
head, and then serious.
(classical music)
I make tuna now.
Smells like strawberry, actually.
I need to make flat, okay, next one is.
(speaks in foreign language)
People say eggs most
important, sushi restaurant.
But I don't think so. (laughs)
Okay, now, I'm kinda enjoy this. (laughs)
It looks like Jell-O, jelly, yes!
Then make ikura, right, yeah.
(xylophone music)
Wow, so science, you know? (laughs)
This looks like ikura, so next,
most one important things
here, this is exactly seaweed,
right here, need to be
stretched, it's gonna be this.
Something weird. (laughs)
Here we go, I believe this is
beautiful seaweed right here.
All done, let's make sushi.
(drum music)
(laughs) Wow, yeah, it's
rice, I make my way.
I think I need to take it
off, fish first, uh oh.
That's funny, this is my tuna today.
It's from Japan and it's beautiful, eggs.
I need to wait a little bit.
Tamango is gonna be a little soft.
Have to wait.
Now, I need to make sushi.
(laughs) Here you go, I'm kind
of shaking, looks like, huh?
One more, sauce sticking
my hand, the same as sushi.
(drum music)
(speaks in foreign language)
There you go. (laughs)
This is my seaweed, right here, come on.
Come on, be nice, we call
the gunkan.
Wow, that's my ikura, there you go!
Come on, eggs, don't be sad,
I pick up a little early,
gonna make scrambled eggs,
I don't waste things.
Unique sushi right here.
There you go, one more, soy sauce here.
Wow. (laughs)
Wow, that flavor is.
(laughs) Yes.
Wow.
(triumphant music)
I think I made a beautiful sushi candy.
I mean, only eggs kinda mess up.
It's not my fault, so I
haven't eat lunch yet.
Let's try a flavor, my famous.
(xylophone music)
(laughs) Wow!
I enjoyed, thank you very
much, enjoy my sushi.
Also, come to my sushi
bar, alright, thank you.
(xylophone music)
- Hey, unsolved is on a new
channel and now your part.
- [Together] Subscribe here.
- That was my part.